a 19 year old Ottawa man has been
arrested for posting numerous threats on
Twitter RCMP say the threats targeted
several political entities in our
Capital Global's Mackenzie gray is
joining us now Mackenzie what do we know
about these charges
well Sonia we're learning new details on
the RCMP laying extremely rare and
serious charges in Ottawa against a 19
year old man Daniel hude has been
charged with 12 different crimes related
to tweets he posted last year where he's
alleged to have threatened to kill
members of parliament allegedly intended
to use a homemade dirty bomb to blow up
both the U.S embassy and the Department
of National Defense here in Ottawa and
he's alleged to have tweeted that he
wanted to burn down the Chinese Embassy
using jet fuel and one match now those
serious threats over Twitter have turned
into major charges from the RCMP hude
faces eight counts of uttering threats
and four counts of hoax regarding a
terrorist activity
this former ceases agent believes the
fact that hude was arrested on terrorism
charges underscores the seriousness of
the alleged threats they've gone for a
higher bioterrorism which is a very
strong indication that within that in
their investigation they've got that
that meet Global News has not seen the
Tweets in question but court documents
state that who tweeted the threats on
November 8th two days later he was
arrested by the RCMP the RCMP would have
initiated a much more in-depth
investigation after his arrest and found
out a lot more that led to the terrorism
possibility terrorism hoax charges have
only been used one other time in Canada
in September 2020 the rcmps charge who
was alleged to have lied to numerous
media Outlets about traveling to Syria
in 2016 to join Isis and commit acts of
extremism but in the end the charges
were dropped as for who'd he's been
released on bail and is due back in
court on January 18th where we're likely
to learn more details on the nature of
the alleged threats so yeah Mackenzie
gray in Ottawa thanks Mackenzie